[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us this
morning a grassroots effort to address
the surging problem of
hunger research shows about one in six
americans or 54 million people could
experience food insecurity
in the wake of the pandemic that
includes 18
million children who may go hungry but
there's a nationwide movement looking to
feed those in need
one healthy bag of food at a time
wednesday mornings are a busy time at
this warehouse in the brownsville
neighborhood of brooklyn new york
boxes of food are delivered by the
pallet watermelons
green peppers tomatoes potatoes
sorted and bags filled to the brim
are loaded back in the trucks to be
distributed throughout the city
but this massive effort also supports a
much humbler one
this is the friendly fridge
a sidewalk refrigerator stocked with
free healthy food for
anyone in need the quality of the food
in here
like those are some serious eggplants
yeah and that's the
important to us that people feel like
they're getting quality
food alexis mena and his brother
franklin run
universe city an organization with a
high-minded mission to create
sustainable food systems
designed by the community employed by
the community
for the benefit of the community in the
last four months we've been able to do
400 000 pounds of food
so that just gives people fresh and
organic food that they might not always
have the opportunity to purchase
themselves eggplant kale
cucumbers wash veggies they see the
fridge as one more way
they can reach their goal what the
fridge allows is a way for people to
connect on their terms
and at their time university and their
food partners like city harvest
now support a loosely linked network of
fridges around new york city
free food fridges have been around for
years but the pandemic created the
circumstances for a grassroots
movement it's a network of individuals
that took an interest
in supporting our community and during
the time where pantries were closing
down
and when they shut down it it left more
and more people especially those who
recently went into unemployment without
the resources they need in order to
be provided for their family and in a
time when you know millions of people
are getting sick and millions of
americans are out of work
and are struggling to put food on the
table this is one way yeah that you're
doing your part
you can now find community fridges
sometimes called
fridges all across the country
each with its own personality like this
one in charlotte north carolina created
by chamel jackson
bread vegetables we have fruits at the
bottom
the fridge at foco cafe in fort collins
colorado is filled with fresh produce
from local farmers
restaurants and gardens from around the
community people are able to come by
grab a handful of carrots or whatever
there might be in here
and be able to feed their families fresh
healthy
locally sourced food these fridges are a
lifeline for people like nick garcia in
new york
who lost his job back in may really been
helping me and
i don't can only imagine how many others
we want to make sure we're inclusive to
everyone
because everyone deserves to eat
and guys i can't stress enough how much
this is about the community the men of
brothers
started university with other
individuals who are all
from the brownsville section of brooklyn
they have deep roots
uh in that community some going back
several generations
and when we were there the place was
buzzing with activity great
i love the term frieges fridges freezes
yeah and just
like you said creating that community
and introducing people also to great
food
may not have that option depending on
where you're at